just looked at the time and I realized
we haven't had a blow up today so one
should be coming in three two
I am who I am and I say what I how I
feel I'm like nice but if I'm pushed I'm
I'm not nice right so it's just that
simple so if you're not pushed and you
say something about me that you said
like I was unstable in the pride I
didn't say that that's not what I said
I'm talking about Kelly Dodd and I said
Kelly's like the new Brandy like you
just say things and don't even think
about consequences or anything and I
said she's just very outgoing she pushes
the envelope things like that never said
you're unstable are you anything no are
you sure because I like I literally
remember you saying I was in stay War
you did nope I never said anything like
that but then you took it to a whole
other level like you called me a
sociopath yeah you said all these things
like I'm like you don't even know me
like you talked about my kids you talked
about my granddaughter like you went
like you went deep Tamara I think you're
a coward please don't ever DM me again
ever yeah sometimes people go low but
you're lower like we're on the sidewalk
here in the gutter maybe you should go
hang out with your grandkids I'm gonna
do the grandkids talk to her
you started it you can't speak about
someone and not expect them to react
this is into the one that I can want it
was the worst like the time of my life
my husband died what does that have to
do with you making money or not right
now oh no you will not talk that way to
me ever let's get that straight you will
never talk that way to me that finger is
interesting you will never talk that way
to me I asked a simple question even eat
my Lobster yet
to have anybody come at me saying shut
up you don't say that to somebody and
scene can we no a scene
you shut up you're three Scorpios like
what are we doing tonight let's get
naked she's Brash her boobs are hanging
out she's disgusting she's filthy her
mouth is filthy birds of a feather flock
together
I am not flocking with that bird okay
just saying
go girl
I don't have sex god knows I'm a Barbie
practically at this point
I mean it's like I practically polish it
to clean it anyway just get some pledge
you're not gonna use that she's not dead
what do you mean you don't think or care
about sex just because you're not
getting it
done like you could use a vibrator I
have one in my suitcase I'm so confused
right now because Serinda is coming
after me for no reason it's her way or
the highway and I don't subscribe to
that I'm sorry Jill okay are they not
what disappoints you about your father
[Music]
well it looks like the blue balls have
appeared we just went from Happy dicks
to Ding Dongs
because you know what you should know
she does know I'm so petrified of mice
and things I actually have that man it
says it on the plaque clear liquid
everyone has a plaque in their room
there's so much going on in that room
off the ceiling Oh no I got it
I'll get the plaque so everyone's very
clear
rats and mice why did she put cupcakes
in our room come here Jill you'll like
the plaque oh I have one myself no shoes
upstairs no food or beverage upstairs
any questions please ask lady no you
don't got it because if something goes
wrong then you're going to get a very
large Bill I'm not a I'm I got it I'm
not a child I got it not I got it I got
it there's no I got it there's no idea
because that's rude and condescending so
if you want to be treated like a child I
can do it don't put food in my bedroom
how's that does now do you understand I
mean are you six years old you sit in
bed with me this is serious like she is
[ __ ] serious she's crying Dorinda
over at the food the way you spoke to
her yeah
like that was kind of insane that was
just like our homes are trash our homes
are no no you said you didn't know so
I'm like I said I don't know how you do
it in your home but here I can't have
food in the room is that a big deal
crying over that that's how I am yeah
I'm gonna cry now because this is my
home
because I just want you to respect my
home like I don't I can't believe just
asking over a simple thing so I was
surprised and you said I didn't know I
assumed something I shouldn't have and
you're gonna make me cry that I didn't
know better I would
tell me
I'm sorry how are you flipping around
then we offended you
guys and in your home people eat in
their bedrooms and stuff no if that's
what you're saying I'm sorry I didn't
understand that you take things
you think that it should be an animal
house no so stop crying about it you're
really crying because I said
God
stop just stop so why didn't you come
today we hide my thing with Tamara
without you ever needed a minute there
we go cool you're asking me a question
I'm telling you without camera's
influence I was just checking out
because I didn't like the way you spoke
you want to do things separately because
you know what there's a lot of conflict
going on with eight women I think I can
pause out but there really isn't
conflict the only underlining conflict
is you
Vicki's been acting like your daughter
who you absolutely love but you don't
understand why do we have a tube what is
the problem what do you want me to do to
not be so negative I'm not negative I'm
a positive you all said you just asked
the question there's your answer we had
a thing it had nothing to do with you
you should have stayed out of it
it was my yogurt
not mine
I had nothing to do with your yogurt or
yours I said it to Tamara and then we
had to say and you jumped in we should
have gotten out there you should have
joined us and you should have shown me
respect as the hostess to do an activity
that I planned for us I'm sorry
all right
well now it's a photo shoot it is
[Music]
I didn't do it your girl Eva did it yell
at her what was happening
crying what is this what happened what
is the thing I'm good okay I saw let me
paraphrase okay
so she just wanted to support you and
she felt as if I'm sorry I didn't mean
to pushed myself on you when you say I
can't do it because it's syndicated I
don't say I'm gonna lay in the bed I'm
sorry if I did that but she feels like
maybe over the years you haven't
supported her as much as she supported
you whoa I don't know if that happened I
haven't seen jokes
[Applause]
[Music]
poor girl wants to go to bed and do a
show leave her alone
it's only gonna tether up for like 500
feet and then come down so don't get
scared I'm just not doing it no oh
you're not doing it I am oh you're not
no I have like a really bad fear of
heights what if a bird flies onto it and
it explodes and I saw on TMZ that one
went down that way so sorry I'm afraid
of heights and I don't need to risk my
life for no reason I have kids
wow this is so cool it's very old
everything's old like everything's
old just feels like death are you
[ __ ] kidding me
give me vodka now we got it
you know what's going on here doing this
drinking I know that it isn't okay and
that's what happens
that's what happens when people go
outside the alcohol drink thank you for
not going after it because too long
don't make a right oh my God
[Music]
I was gonna you still try to beat up I
know that murder that lady could be your
mama you can't do that no she's only
five years older foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
people dying [ __ ] get out of my face
I literally will not [ __ ] with you you
don't want this I really feel sorry for
Dorinda because I think that she's out
of control on all levels you just gotta
chill but she's [ __ ] with the wrong
[ __ ] we're all gonna die we're all
gonna die and that's why life is so
precious to me because we're all gonna
die and I don't know when it's gonna
happen but you experience joy every day
you can nobody talks about death as much
as Vicky like oh
you know what's going to be sad is one
day when one of us dies
don't go there
listen to me just be grateful that we
have our health and our families and
move on from there and be paused out did
you have too much champagne oh I did
take it all I just feel like it's the
most she's just
if I died right now you guys I want you
all to know you tell everybody that she
died sad
because you know what I want to die with
joy in my heart you're not going to hang
on let you cause we that's not gonna be
the Legacy she died sad she died sad
we're gonna put that on your Tombstone
I'm extremely offended that nobody wants
to have sex with me how could that be
not me I like a little box oh God I like
your little box too it's right my face
she likes a little tight box so that's
from Taylor that's ironic because you're
drawn to my energy we have made out
before it's so fast
well no don't get too excited
[Music]
ill okay then
like wow if Randy doesn't stop someone's
gonna get pregnant I'm really
embarrassed that
Steve has decided to end the
relationship while I'm on a trip so I I
know it's hurtful for Vicki but
here she
here
I don't love you I'm moving on do you
want to walk out there crying or you
want to no I'm not crying nobody yeah
Randy don't you flip this show I am oh I
am not gonna I promise you I don't want
anything to do with this water on that
level ready yeah there's no seat belt in
here I don't know how I feel about this
I don't know how I feel because how deep
is this water wait wait everybody just
calm down everybody just calm down okay
just breathe
let's just float for a minute
all the people that are here I will look
forward to going tomorrow is kind of
Brandy because she's a lot of work
Brandy is high maintenance the way she's
almost like having a teenager in the
house again like don't touch the stove
when she touches the stove don't play
with fire and she plays with fire I mean
she's a lot of fun but she's mischievous
I'm not even going to feed into the
things
please don't yeah please don't you're
right you're right you're right I
promise leave on a good note yeah have
fun
help
Phaedra I need someone to push it or sit
on it do I have to carry this down
I'm not carrying this down am I you're
gonna get on the bed oh my God
[Music]
that's how I broke my nail
myself thank you oh you do thank you
I have to run back and pack myself all
right I'm almost done lady I'm almost
done too the cookout is always there
when you need them
come on everyone come on down
[Music]